we are approaching Halloween time we'll
talk everything Halloween what costumes
are you allowed to wear and most
importantly what costumes are you not
allowed to wear Plus Hillary Clinton
says she's totally innocent and Bill
O'Reilly says the same thing and neither
of them has a ton of evidence to support
that we'll talk about all of those
things I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show yes here we are it is yet
another day in the most beautiful
country on God's earth but there are
problems in paradise
those problems include whether to allow
your child to dress as mallanna yes
seriously this is what we are now going
to have a big fight about I'll explain
in just a second but first I want to
thank our sponsors over at zip recruiter
dot-com so are you in need of great
talent but you don't have a lot of time
to waste well we here at the Daily wire
use the prakruti all the time in order
to recruit new candidates for our jobs
and you can too right now zip recruiter
allows you to post your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards with
just one click
then zip recruiter puts it smart
matching technology to work actively
notifying qualified candidates about
your job within minutes of posting so
you'll receive the best possible message
and the message matches and then the
messages just start pouring in super
cooter is different because it doesn't
depend on the right candidates finding
you it finds them for you using their
proprietary technology 80% of employers
who post on zip recruiter get equality
Kansas through the site in just one day
it is that fast
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire find out today why zip recruiter
has been used by growing businesses of
all sizes and industries to find the
most qualified job candidates with great
results you can post your jobs for free
right now on zip recruiter for free at
zip recruiter dot-com slash daily wire
that zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
go ahead and check it out because again
if you need the best employee for the
best possible situation the zip
recruiters the way to do it zip
recruiter comm slash daily where we use
it here at the daily wire and you can
too okay so as we approach Halloween it
is that time of the year for us to have
stupid conversations about what sort of
costumes you can and cannot wear now I
am NOT of the opinion that every costume
is appropriate because that would be
foolish but I'm also not of the opinion
that just because one person is offended
by a costume unreasonably that means
that the costume is inherently
or terrible or racist or any of that
stuff particularly when you're talking
about children's costumes I do think
there's a difference in kind between
children's costumes and adults costumes
so very often you'll see adults who
should know better dressing as things in
order to mock the culture that they're
wearing something up so for example if
my little daughter were to dress as as
Princess Tiana from a Disney movie you
know even put on blackface presumably
but if you were to dressed as Princess
Tiana from from princess and frog then
nobody would be offended by that because
she's a little girl if my wife were to
do the same thing people might have some
more questions there is a difference
between children's costumes and adult
costumes and I think that that's worth
noting by the way I do think that the
whole motion of adults dressing up for
Halloween I'm not the biggest fan unless
you have a child just a general rule
like I have a kid so both of us dress up
in costumes for poram for example and
I'm poor him everybody dresses up I'm
not sure that that adults dressing up
for Halloween and like making a huge
deal out of it unless it's like a cutesy
thing is really is really a thing cuz it
turns out that most people are just
looking to get drunk and participate in
various activities which I would not
approve and so you got like nurse
costumes and such not not my favorite
thing in any case the left has decided
that it must set some standards however
and the standards for white people is
you cannot dress up as anything but
yourself or an inanimate object that is
culturally stereo sterile basically it
has no cultural sort of weight even
dressing up is like a Rubik's Cube like
that would be that they light or spoon
like a spoon would be good right you can
dress up as a letter of the alphabet you
can't dress up as anything else because
if you do you're likely to offend
someone so if you're a white person
particularly you have to be very very
careful about these standards and now
the left is extending these standards
down to children so there's an amazing
piece in Cosmopolitan magazine that was
going around yesterday that I have to go
through because it does reveal you know
a culture that is is determined to be
oversensitive about things that don't
matter is going to be a culture that
tears itself apart and this is a perfect
example of that we should all be
sensitive to the cultural concerns of
others I think that's that's appropriate
I mean I really do actually but I also
think that if you are looking to be
offended then you're going to find
something to be offended about the
latest iteration is Cosmo has written a
has put out a piece by the red book
editors that says that you should not
allow your child your daughter to dress
asthma
for Halloween mallanna is of course the
Polynesian princess from from the
self-titled movie Moana and because
she's Polynesian they're not saying that
if you have a well if you if you have
white kid then your kid should not be
allowed to dress up as Moana and the
article is just a masterpiece of
stupidity so I really want to go through
it cuz I think it's it speaks to where
we are in the culture and you want to
know how you got trumped this I got from
the feeling that everyone is
oversensitive about stupid crap is how
you got Trump and then Trump says stuff
that people should be sensitive about
and then they're not sensitive about it
and so things get worse in any case here
are the red book editors from Cosmo what
I tweeted was I'll take advice on how to
dress my child for Halloween when Cosmo
stops telling me to abort my child or
raise them gender-neutral
in any case the piece starts like this
it's mid October which means Halloween
is just two weeks away which means it's
way past time to decide on a Halloween
costume for your kid first of all I mean
then itself is stereotypical I mean how
could you decide for your child how
patriarchal are you chances are you have
a child that is enamored with all things
Disney and wants to be all of the
princesses all of them especially
mallanna
the New York Post recently highlighted
an article on race race-conscious org
which seems like a terrible way to spend
your day reading race-conscious org
about how that's probably not a good
choice if your kid is white then
revealed that moms are freaking out over
the culturally appropriate of costume as
I've said before cultural appropriation
is idiotic it's one thing for you to
take something that has deep spiritual
meaning and then market it is another
thing for you to say you know it's great
Italian food you know it's awesome
Chinese food you know it's pretty cool
hoop earrings like really if you're
getting oversensitive about this stuff
folks you really need a life then it
says needless to say the post coverage
has only amplified the debate around
what does or does in constitute cultural
appropriation
last year Disney came under fire for its
Maui costume which depicted the demigods
painted brown skin and I looked this up
apparently Disney released a costume
from from one of the characters in the
film was played by Dwayne the rock
Johnson and the costume involved having
brown skin I guess and this was a big
controversy and so they had to pull the
costume and basically I'm looking it up
right now the reason people were angry
is because the costume itself was a
brown skinned bodysuit adorned with
Polynesian tattoos and a full leaf skirt
and two sets of legs with thick dark
hair
top off the Maui and Moana look and this
is just terrible because for some reason
that I don't understand because Maui is
a Polynesian in the movie so that's kind
of weird like they weren't saying that
you should paint your face black they're
saying this is what Maui looks like we
all have eyes people are different
colors in any case I don't think that it
was you know just the worst thing that
ever was in any case the company
ultimately pulled the costume in
response to the uproar saying the team
behind mallanna has taken great care to
respect the cultures of the Pacific
Islands that inspired the film and we
regret that the Maui costume has
offended some the Maui at question may
have been settled but this year there
are plenty of tweets out there asking
the internet and lin-manuel Miranda if
it's okay to dress up as Moana for
Halloween first of all I think we have
to ask a question why should lin-manuel
Miranda be able to write the music for a
movie about Polynesians why not a
Polynesian person writing Polynesian
music for a movie about Polynesians
lin-manuel Miranda's in Polynesia as far
as I'm aware I think is the original
article written by Sachi Faris discusses
how her white daughter was torn between
dressing as Elsa from frozen or the
titular character from Moana Ferris
expresses concern that while in Elsa
costume might reinforce notions of white
privilege dressing up as Moana is
essentially cultural appropriation the
act of reducing someone's culture to
stereotypes and thereby belittling it
though fairest puzzles over how one
might wear Moana costume respectfully
she ultimately decides it just isn't a
good idea so let's get this straight the
left is saying your daughter can't dress
up as a Polynesian girl that she admires
because that's bad because something we
can't have heroes who are cross-cultural
we just can't do it
Jews have to dress up like Jews white
folks who are not Jewish or Italian or
German have to dress up like those
people basically dress up as yourself as
these the Halloween advice from the left
is here for white people I do love the
idea that she can't dress up as Elsa cuz
that would be that would be ethnocentric
but she should dress up as she she also
can't trust up as Moana because that
would be cultural appropriation I'm a
little dizzy at this point says at this
point you might be saying something like
but I just dressed up as jasmine as a
child and I'm not a racist or it's just
a Halloween costume please chill the f
out right I'm saying both of those
things but I didn't dress up as Jasmine
but one of the best things about time is
that it moves forward you should too
this is Cosmo you can and should strive
to be better than you were ten twenty or
thirty years ago
well how about more intelligent because
it sounds like you just want us to be
dumber than we were ten years ago if you
miss the mark when you were younger
maybe think about using this Halloween
as an opportunity to teach your kid
about the importance of cultural
sensitivity if your child's dream
costume feels questionable don't just
throw up your hands and hand over your
credit card you're the parent here and
the onus of what your child wears falls
on you if your kid wears a racist
costume you're kind of learning it too I
just want to note here a little bit of
an incongruity and I love that sentence
you're the parent here right if your
child's dream costume feels questionable
don't throw up your hands and hand over
your credit card you're the parent here
unless your child is a boy who declares
that he's a girl in which case you're
not the parent here shut the F up and
hand them over to a pediatrician for
help for hormone blockers then you're
not the parents if your kids decides
their kid is a member of the opposite
sex then you're not the parent anymore
but if your kid wants to dress up like
Moana well damn it step in don't you
understand the kind of damage you're
doing to the country okay but it gets
even better recognize this Moana is a
really special character to young girls
of Polynesian descent who have never
seen the Disney princess who looks like
them just like how Ayanna from The
Princess and the Frog likely resonated
with young black women could waited
decades to see themselves represented
okay so white girls have plenty of
princesses to choose from there's Belle
Ariel Snow White Sleeping Beauty you get
the idea
well I guess that only mermaids can
dress up as Ariel and as far as as far
as these other characters none of them
are Jewish so what does my daughter do
I just don't know is it white cultural
appropriation for her to dress up as
Cinderella she's really big into
Cinderella if you're caucasian son or
daughter doesn't get to be exactly what
they wanted for Halloween encourage them
to take a step back and realize that
there are washing privileges that the
real moana xin Tiana's of the world will
likely never see because the world is
full of racist a-holes I'm gonna go with
if you are so race-conscious that you
think that you can't admire someone of a
different color or ethnicity you may be
one of the racist a-holes you might want
to take a look in the mirror but here's
the here's the best part of the article
basically the article says you can't
dress your daughter as Moana because
Trump really I'm not making this up like
this is how you got Trump times 1,000
and those a-holes are becoming ever more
empowered Wright's Cosmo our president
is a hate group apologist who tried to
ban refugees from seeking asylum in our
country simply because of their faith
meanwhile black Americans continue to be
killed by police and anti-semitic voices
feel louder and more powerful than they
have in decades so what does this have
to do with a seemingly innocuous
princess costume pretty much everything
really that's what the article says I'm
not making this up it's important to
align with and stand up for people of
color and minorities and a key part of
that is showing respect for their
cultures to pretend to be a racial
ethnic or religious minority when you're
not makes light of their history and
reinforces a deeply problematic power
dynamic when white people use then
discard pieces of culture they've
subjugated for centuries just because
they can and they say that your kids can
still sing Moana songs I don't know why
and then but they but you're not allowed
to allow your kid to to actually dress
up as Moana and then Fijian Emmeline
Mataji suggests using your kids desire
to be Moana or Maui as an opportunity to
teach them about actual Polynesian
culture that's fine but why can't they
dress up as those people yeah well as
I've said before every year when I was
growing up when I was a child I dressed
up as John Adams John Adams not a Jew
right John Adams a Christian founding
father I used to get in that costume
every year because I was a huge John
Adams fan because I grew up on the movie
1776 was that culturally appropriate in
John Adams was that making light the
whole point of your kid wearing a
costume is their kid is saying the
costume is cool it's that simple
end of story but this is how you get
Trump really it's the oversensitivity
and the deliberate oversensitivity
and the attempts to paint everyone who
is not willing to fall for this
microaggressions culture as racist that
is the serious problem and it's why
people are rejecting this nonsense
wholesale okay before I go any further
and I'm gonna talk about the president
Trump bob Corker spat that has now
broken out because it's a day ending in
Y which means that somebody is in a
fight with President Trump and President
Trump is in a fight with somebody
none of which actually affords policy by
the way I'm not just being gonna be
critical of Trump's policy there's a
good story about Trump's policy I want
to tell you two but first I want to say
thank you to our new sponsors over at
saucy so everyone at some point has
wished they could just have beer wine or
liquor delivered direct to their home
particularly during this news cycle
particularly when everything is so
depressing
sometimes you wish that someone would
just deliver a bottle of whiskey to your
house well now there is such a service
this is saucy okay it's the alcohol
delivery app they deliver your favorite
wine beer and liquor right to your door
on demand we've used it for vodka in the
Shapiro home it is the lyft or uber for
alcohol if you're in LA San Francisco
Chicago San Diego or Sacramento your
saucy order will
at your door in 30 minutes or less ready
to drink and for the rest of us
saucy will deliver beer wine and liquor
to your door in two days or less
nationwide no order minimums no delivery
fees no running to the store you're
sitting at home you're watching the news
you're depressed or you're sitting at
home watching a romantic movie with your
significant other and you just want a
bottle of something that's what saucy is
for if you've got the saucy app you've
got a fully stocked bar on your phone
you don't have to go out and spend
hundreds of dollars on every possible
drink that you might want instead you
just call for a drink when you want a
drink for a limited time you can get $15
off when you download the saucy app and
enter promo code been again 15 bucks off
when you download the saucy app and
enter promo code Ben that's the saucy
app spelled si you see ey si you see ey
and enter promo code Ben for $15 off get
that saucy app today and use promo code
Ben as I've said before there are
certain things in life that just make
you feel wealthy even when you're not
saucy app is one of those things that
does it's basically like having a butler
who can bring you liquor when you want
it which is pretty awesome saucy si you
see ey and enter the promo code Ben
after you download the app and get $15
off your order
okay so meanwhile well the rest of the
world fights over Halloween costumes you
know people tend to think that this
Halloween costume thing is irrelevant
except that it's not okay at Yale
University last year or two years ago
Erica Christakis was the head of the
shoes the I guess the Resident Advisor
at silliman College which is a place
that a bunch of students live Eagle and
she wrote a letter to people saying
basically you know don't be offensive if
you can avoid it but if you're offended
maybe take a second thought about why
you're offended and whether it's
worthwhile being offended about
Halloween costumes the students went
completely insane there was all sorts of
video of the students screaming and her
husband Nicholas Christakis
who's a very famous professor and
yelling at him and telling him to shut
up and listen to them because they're
people of color in many cases and he is
a white guy and so he should shut up and
listen to them because their opinions
are important and his not and his wife's
letter made them feel unsafe etc etc he
ended up resigning his position at
silliman college and so did she
this sort of thing is happening all over
the country over at University of Texas
at Austin they actually put out a guide
as to what sort of costumes you should
you should think about wearing for
Halloween so as not to offend everyone
and they legitimately come up with
things like don't dress up like Cowboys
or Indians because that might be a
offensive to someone don't dress up as
you can't switch off of the border party
so you can't do anything that is a
Mexico related you know they they did a
whole stick about why you should you
should not dress up as as various
members of other cultures and then what
do they leave like you can dress up as a
Rubik's Cube dead serious this is what
they suggest that you should dress up as
a Rubik's Cube they also suggest that
perhaps you should dress up as as
letters of the alphabet we know that
certain letter which I find weird
because certain letters of the alphabet
are inherently offensive like the
letters W and T I mean T will remind
people of Trump and might trigger them
and W will remind you of W in might
trigger decade time period they say she
dress up in like a 50s outfit but
doesn't that ignore the plight of women
during the 50s they say you can dress up
as comic-book heroes and villains what
if you're a culturally appropriating
kriptonite culture who Kryptonian
culture how do you know and then my
favorite one here is that you should
you're allowed to dress up as kattiline
the yacht mixer or preppy so you can do
a cultural stereotype of a white guy in
boat shoes but you can't do any other
sort of cultural stereotype well done
University of Texas at Austin again this
is the sort of stuff that tears us apart
needlessly everybody should take a deep
breath because in that important but
we're gonna have a big fuss over it this
year I promise you this is just the
beginning of the stupid Halloween
stories ok so meanwhile in more
important news president Trump is on the
hill trying to push through his tax
reform package today we still don't know
exactly what that package looks like
there's been a lot of talk about it what
exactly that will look like when all is
said and done there's been some talk
about it including revisions to form 1 k
plans Trump rightly has said he is not
going to do that which is good there's
been some talk about not lowering the
top tax bracket which is stupid the top
tax bracket should be lowered and that's
not just cuz I'm a member of the top tax
bracket I felt that way before I was a
member of the top tax bracket the reason
being the people who actually hire you
and create your jobs are very often
members of the top tax bracket ok beyond
that there's a lot of controversy over
what this will include and Trump has a
very fractious caucus a very fractious
caucus and when I say very fractious I
mean that Trump has he was saddled with
a Senate that only has 52 votes Lisa
Murkowski and Susan Collins and John
McCain and Rand Paul are always going to
be iffy on anything Rand Paul barely
votes for anything because you
to maintain his supposed purity and lisa
murkowski and suzanne collins are very
left-leaning republicans so hard to get
them to vote for anything and trump has
exacerbated some of these problems by
going directly to war with some of these
with some of these senators so the
person who he's currently at war with is
bob corker the senator from tennessee
he's been angry at bob corker for
several weeks now because corker has
been sounding off about President Trump
now I am NOT about corker fan I think
bob corker is as woozy and slimy as it
is possible to be in the United States
Senate bob corker is the guy behind the
Senate approval for the Iran ziyal bob
corker is a guy who was happy to back
President Trump all the way up till the
election and then flirt with being
Secretary of State before he decided to
turn on him
so now bob corker is going out in public
and yelling basically at President Trump
talking about how terrible he is here as
bob Corker ripping him this morning the
constant non truth-telling the just the
name-calling the things like i think the
the basement of our nation will be what
he'll be remember most for and that's
regretful and it affects young people i
mean we have young people who for the
first time or you know watching a
president stating you know absolute non
truth non stop personalizing things in
the way that he does and and it's it's
very sad furnace there's corker trumpets
defacing our nation the only thing is
gonna remember for it is to basing our
nation dude you're a part of that too
basement if this is the way that you
feel like thank you for taking no
political risk now that you said you're
not running for reelection and then
coming out and ripping trump in the
middle of a tax reform fight but this is
why you know all the talk about
ideological relations on the hill a lot
of it's nonsense a lot of it since our
personal like john mccain and trump
despise one another
the same thing is now true of bob Corker
bob Corker didn't stop there he then
ripped into Trump even more so and then
Trump ripped back I've been with him on
multiple occasions to try to you know
create some kind of aspirational
approach if you will to the way that he
conducts himself but I don't think that
that's possible and
he's obviously not going to to rise to
the occasion as president
okay so there's bob Corker ripping trump
up and down and Trump responds not by
trying to tamp things down by saying
this bob Corker who helped President
Obama give us the batter on Zeile and
couldn't get elected dog catcher in
Tennessee is now fighting tax cuts fair
corker dropped out of the race in
Tennessee when I refused to endorse him
and now his only negative on anything
Trump look at his record isn't it sad
that lightweight senator bob Corker who
couldn't get reelected in the great
state of tennessee will now fight tax
cuts plus senator corker is the
incompetent head of the Foreign
Relations Committee and look how poorly
the US has done he doesn't have a clue
as the entire world was laughing and
taking advantage of us people like
little bob corker have set the u.s. way
back now we move forward okay first of
all I do like that Trump does have a
rotating series of about ten insults and
he just keeps going around and around
it's sort of like the old photo rotation
that you had at your grandparents house
it's just quick okay time for new insult
little Li ddle
' for some reason bob Corker the
question here is not whether Trump is
right about corker I just said corkers
Busey and slimy okay I think that that's
basically correct the question is is
this effective in pushing your
legislation I'm gonna go no I'm gonna
say this probably isn't super effective
in pushing your legislation
good luck pushing through tax reform
when bob Corker lisa murkowski
susan collins rand paul and john mccain
are all part of your caucus and all of
them hate you
you know this is where some of trumps
wheeling and dealing would have been
really nice but the problem is that
Trump was never that guy and this is a
point where presidential relations does
matter there's sort of this assumption
that net look this here's what's gonna
happen
all these senators are gonna vote
against tax reform Trump's gonna play
McConnell the Trump base will blame
McConnell because it's convenient to
blame McConnell and everyone will forget
about how Trump said that McCain was not
a war hero and suggest that bob Corker
is disgusting and has gone after Rand
Paul now they're friends again I guess
but they'll be enemies again soon enough
you know none of this is particularly
helpful and none of it pushes
legislation which is why a lot of the
accomplishments of the Trump
administration are basically happening
at the executive level
virtually none are happening at the
legislative level so in in good news
Molly Hemingway reports at over at the
Federalist that the Trump administration
there have been about 13,000 new
regulations added to the federal rules
every year for the last
two years or so the Trump administration
is added basically zero that is a very
good thing we don't need more useless
regulations that have not been approved
by the American people so on the
executive side the stuff that Trump can
control it seems like a lot of it is
going pretty well the stuff that he can
get let's put this way the stuff that he
can control and is allowing his team to
do what they're supposed to do all of
that is going fine right all of the
regulatory cuts all of the judicial
nominations all the stuff where he takes
his hands off all that's going fine all
the major legislative pushes though
those are collapsing into sands and
there are personality problems here
personalities do matter in politics
george w bush was a backslapper and a
guy who got along with people
Barack Obama at least hit that with his
own party he a lien Aidid all the
Republicans but he did that with his own
party I don't think that you see the
same thing from President Trump which is
kind of amazing I'm not again I'm not
blaming Trump for all of this because I
think the Democrats were motivated to go
against him from the very start but
Trump came into office is one of the
guys on these supposed it rights out of
the aisle who was very friendly with
Democrats he'd worked with Chuck Schumer
he'd worked in Nancy Pelosi and now it
seems we've fallen into this this
basically three prong scenario none of
which are fantastic one is only
executive actions gets on we can share
that but if Trump loses then the
executive actions get reversed day one -
nothing gets done in Congress at all
because he can't get his own caucus
together and three he surrenders to
Pelosi and Schumer as supposedly he was
going to do with daca none of these are
glorious outcomes that's why President
Trump really needs to focus and really
needs to do a little bit of wooing if
we're gonna get anything done here at
all now I want to talk about the crisis
among Democrats as well as Bill O'Reilly
controversy in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Skillshare so let me just tell
you the job market is incredibly fluid
right the job market is is incredibly
fluid meaning that people move job the
job you're no longer at the same job for
20 years if you are it's only because
you're constantly increasing and
improving your skillset the only way
that I know to do this in really
effective fashion repeatedly is with my
friends over at Skillshare they've over
three million members more than 17,000
classes it is the Netflix for online
learning skills share allows you to take
classes and things like graphic design
DSLR photography social media marketing
digital illustration and much more and
skills share classes are taught by
industry experts and experienced
professionals / for
if you're looking to build your career
or start the side hustle of your dreams
so I have personally taken their
watercolor class and let me tell you I
am now Monet I'm just amazing at
watercolors but beyond that I'm now
taking a more important class I think
for me anyway
social media marketing and that is very
useful in the business that we are in
Skillshare allows you to take these
45-minute classes and increase your
skill set on a routine basis next time
you're sitting with your boss and your
boss says does anyone in the room know
how to do X you're gonna know how to do
X because you have skills share or at
least you can Phibbs I know how to do it
go home google it
go on Skillshare find the class that
you're looking for and then learn what
you need to know skills share is giving
my listeners a one-month free trial of
unlimited access to over 17,000 classes
go to skills shared comm slash Shapiro
that skill shared calm slash Shapiro and
start your free month today once you
start it you're not gonna want to stop
at skills shared comm slash up hero go
check it out
okay so meanwhile in other news the big
news over the weekend was of course this
big report from the New York Times that
Bill O'Reilly had apparently paid out a
thirty two million dollar settlement on
some sort of unspecified sexual
harassment allegations a New York Times
reporter was on television yesterday
talking about how Bill O'Reilly was
trying to quash the story I don't think
he thought he could get us to not write
the story but maybe he thought that he
could bully us into not doing it or get
us you know sort of push us into not
doing it it certainly wasn't the type of
interview where he tried to charm us it
was clear from the beginning that this
would be unlike any other interview that
I certainly had ever been in where you
know he was going to as hard as he could
to make the case that this was this was
not fair and now that we weren't really
following the facts and we spent a lot
of time there just asking him questions
to try and learn as much as possible
okay so this this obviously did not work
the New York Times ended up writing a
very very lengthy hit piece on Bill
O'Reilly O'Reilly is fighting back
against what he called wise and smears
megyn kelly as he played yesterday said
that she had complained to the
administrators over at fox news about
bill o'reilly treatment of women going
back years and years and years there was
there's a settlement from Fox News and
Bill O'Reilly against with with regard
to one of his producers woman in Deandra
Makris who I had once met when she was
producing O'Reilly show that's when you
heard all the tapes about
Bill O'Reilly basically calling her up
and leaving messages on her machine of a
sexual nature she posted so Bill
O'Reilly has posted on his website three
notes so one is from megyn kelly and her
husband
it says dear bill what a class act you
are coming to my baby shower I was truly
touched I know how busy you are
especially that time of day it meant a
lot to me and Doug and thank you for the
darling bodysuits and snuggly it's hard
to believe we'll soon have a little
human being in our lives tiny enough to
fit in this you become a dear friend no
matter what you say and I'm Brett I'm
grateful to have you in my life and then
there was another one from megyn kelly
that said thanks for the plug on Doug's
book I realize you didn't have to do
that especially after mentioning it
already I appreciate how supportive
you've been of me over the years here at
Fox News Channel you're a true friend
and mentor megyn kelly and then there's
one from gretchen carlson who also has
suggested there's reality to the rumors
about about bill o'reilly and it says
bill thank you for being the calm in the
seats then thank you so much for
supporting me thank you for being my
friend it means the world to me gretchen
carlson so this is being used as proof
that bill o'reilly did not do all of
these things so a couple of things one
very hard to imagine a personal thirty
two million dollar settlement in a case
where there's no evidence very very
difficult to imagine that so all of this
is alleged because settlements are
confidential but difficult to imagine
nothing happened here difficult to
imagine and I have a feeling more
stories are gonna come out in the near
future second these thank-you notes
don't really say a lot the reason I say
they don't say a lot is because people
write thank-you notes to each other all
the time for attending events they're
constantly saying nice things and polite
things to each other
because they need them for career
purposes or because they work for them
or work with them that they don't
actually mean I mean if you go back and
read my book bullies I say some nice
things about Steve Bannon that I can say
in all fairness were probably motivated
by the fact that I was working for Steve
Bannon at the time in any case I don't
think that that stuff is particularly
rare in the business because again
everybody needs to scratch each other's
back when it comes career time but that
doesn't say anything about the nature of
these allegations
O'Reilly also released in affidavit from
a woman named les wheel or lists wheel
sorry she's a former Fox News legal
analyst and he claims on his web site
the affidavit repudiates all allegations
against him but this is not true
basically the affidavit says from list
wheel that she's known bill o'reilly for
over 18 years we have worked together we
have socialized and on a
I gave him legal advice and says at the
end of 2016 I hired counsel who prepared
a draft complaint asserting claims
against Bill O'Reilly we've since
resolved all of our issues I would no
longer make the allegations contained in
the draft complaint well of course not
once you settle that bars you from
making the allegations in the draft
complaint so that doesn't help at all it
says additionally over the years while I
was acting as Bill O'Reilly's counsel he
forwarded to me certain explicit emails
that were sent to him and any advice
sought or rendered his attorney-client
privileged confidential and private I
have no claims against Bill O'Reilly
concerning any of those emails or any of
the allegations in the draft complaint
write again once you settle things you
can't sue based on them so because the
settlement is approved by the court so
the idea that Bill O'Reilly is is off
the hook on this not legally true just
as a lawyer says also I've reached an
accommodation with Fox News regarding
the termination of my employment I have
no claims against Fox News again she
doesn't have claims against Fox News
because she settled all of them so that
doesn't tend to do much the reason that
I point this out is because there's
gonna be a tendency that I think we all
ought to avoid on both sides to say
Harvey Weinstein is guilty because I'm
right-wing or Bill O'Reilly is innocent
because I'm right-wing or vice versa
on the left and you see the ratings on
CNN and MSNBC every time they talk
weinstein according to Yashiro lee over
at Huffington Post in the Atlantic he
says every time CNN and MSNBC cover
Harvey Weinstein the ratings plummeted
cover Reilly the ratings go up that's
because people want to believe things
about people they don't like
so let's not fall into that trap given
the the evidence on the table a thirty
two million dollar alleged settlement
and the evidence that O'Reilly has
produced this is not quell my suspicions
O'Reilly said yesterday in an interview
that he was angry at God if the
allegations are true I've a feeling the
feeling might be mutual again I don't
think that we should make light of
people on our own side doing bad things
just because they're on our own side
speaking of which the Democrats continue
to defend Hillary Clinton which is very
exciting so the new allegations about
Hillary Clinton have basically been that
Hillary Clinton sold essentially 20% of
the uranium of the United States or her
State Department did to Raza Tom which
was the Russian Atomic Energy Agency and
that at the same time the Russians were
giving all sorts of money to the Clinton
Foundation the FBI and zio Jay knew
about it and did nothing
Hillary Clinton came out yesterday and
she said no no all this has been
debunked don't you understand it's been
debunked
I would say it's the same baloney
they've been peddling for years and
there's been no no credible evidence by
anyone in fact it's been debunked
repeatedly and will continue to be
debunked but here's what they're doing
and really I have to give them credit
you know Trump and his allies including
Fox News are really experts at
distraction and diversion so the closer
the investigation about real Russian
ties between Trump associates and real
Russians as we heard Jeff Sessions
finally admit to in his testimony the
other day the more they want to just
throw mud on the wall and I'm their
favorite target me and you know
President Obama we're the ones that they
always like to put into the crosshairs
so let's have the know it shows what
she's saying here first of all I do I
love c-span book TV I've been on it a
couple of times it's always a lot of fun
I do like their doing this from her
kitchen apparently I went from grandma's
kitchen but in any case Hillary
Clinton's saying that she's completely
innocent this is why she lost right I
mean one of the reasons she lost is
because she obviously wasn't and most of
the evidence that is now coming out
about events that happened with regard
to Russia actually is blowing back on
things like the Podesta group not on
Trump per se at least the stuff that's
being leaked so we still have to reserve
our judgment on what exactly has
happened here but it doesn't look good
for Hillary Clinton and people on the
Left who are willing to sort of brush
away all of this are making a mistake I
think trey Gowdy who is the the head of
the the house investigative subcommittee
House Judiciary and oversight committee
he announced on Tuesday a joint
investigation into how the FBI handled
last year's investigation into Hillary
Clinton's private email server this I
think is completely appropriate because
once again I think it's pretty clear
that that James Comey had pre decided
the outcome of how this is going to work
before before it actually happened so
that is another controversy that just
will not die okay so I want to get to
some things I like some things I hate
and then we'll deconstruct a little bit
of culture so let's jump right in so
let's begin with things I like today so
things I like I just finished reading
all the way through Maimonides guide to
the perplexed so people are constantly
asking what's a good book about kind of
Jewish philosophy there's pretty
sophisticated book about Jewish
philosophy by Moses Maimonides who has
won probably the most famous rabbi in
the
post-biblical era Maimonides Rambam as
he is called in the Jewish community
because he's Moses Ben diamond so rabbi
Moses Ben diamond our mbm right or ish
mm mm so Rambam was the the author of
the guide for the perplexed this was a
series of letters that he basically
wrote to one of his students all about
trying to square religion with
secularism and it's quite fascinating
especially because there's a bit of a
misconception inside some parts of the
Orthodox Jewish community that secular
learning doesn't play a role in how
great rabbinic minds have thought about
the world half of this book is basically
a restatement of Aristotelian theories
about the creation of the universe
and arguments about it my mom he was
deeply engaged in secular culture and
that's what makes the guide for the
perplexed so interesting he talks about
the questions of freewill versus
determinism he talks about the questions
of God's God's providence over the
universe he talks about questions about
why bad things happen to good people
it's really interesting this thing was
written in the 11th in the 12th century
rather and it's still readable that this
translation that you see up on your
screen here was written I think it was
1979 and it's a pretty good translation
now it is sophisticated you should
probably do some reading about Aristotle
before you read this I would suggest as
I've mentioned Edward phasors books on
Aristotelian theory that gives you a
good background in this what's really
fascinating culturally is that the guide
for the perplexed was basically written
at about the same time as Thomas Aquinas
was writing Summa Theologica
and they mirror a lot of their their
logic which makes a lot of sense because
Aquinas was a Christian thinker who
believes in the Old Testament Moses
Maimonides was a Jewish thing crow
believes in the Old Testament and both
of them believed in Aristotle so the the
attempts to square a tryst is healing in
theory with judeo-christian belief is
one of their missions it's something in
which I deeply believe it's go watch my
speech at University of Tennessee
Knoxville if you're interested in seeing
how I think this plays into the American
Founding I'm actually writing a book on
all of this right now that I'm looking
forward to to pushing up probably
sometime next year okay other things
that I like so yesterday I showed you
the CNN ad talking about how an apple is
just an apple almost of course it's not
so a fellow named Greg Tomlin friend of
mine producer over at Michael Medved
show he cut this ad in response to the
CNN ad this is a man some people might
try to tell you it's a woman
they might scream woman woman woman over
and over and over again they might put
woman in all caps you might even start
to believe that this is a woman but it's
not this is a man so thanks to great
talent very funny stuff obviously I see
and then does not believe that which is
why whenever they do the we are the
facts Network you just go no okay time
for a couple of things I hate them will
deconstruct some culture so things that
I hate
so speaking of useless invocation of
racism for no particular reason except
to annoy people Jesse Jackson who again
should really have very little to say
about things
racial Jesse Jackson given the fact that
you know he used to call New York
town and such Jesse Jackson made the
statement on undisputed on Fox Sports 1
that first of all I don't know why Jesse
Jackson is even on a sports channel why
is Jesse Jackson on a sports channel I
love that Rush Limbaugh was booted off
ESPN for saying that Donovan McNabb was
overrated
and Jesse Jackson it's totally fine for
him to be on a sports channel talking
about his perspectives on sports what
he's about to say here is so utterly
nuts that I just have to play it for you
here's Jesse Jackson all the fragrances
around the world all their or their
wages and they've been their benefits to
Krishna who paid the price of rebelling
against the system of oppression and it
is oppressive to go from picking cotton
balls to picking footballs and
basketballs without freedom it is not
very much progress it's just a lot of
move and what strikes me is that in full
of the reason why so many guys are
standing when the president says fire
them every time my son sees was or not
son yes sons of mothers who produced
champions they're not something this
really are in case I don't understand
what he's saying in the last part
because his Jesse Jackson's patterns of
speech are difficult to decipher
sometimes but what he is saying at the
beginning there is he says that to go
from picking cotton balls to picking
footballs and basketballs without
freedom is not very much progress this
is so insane it's so insipid
suggest that the football players were
earning millions of dollars to play
football or basketball players who are
basketball and they don't have freedom
things say whatever they want off the
court they can do whatever they want off
the field you know this idea they don't
have freedom I am an employee right or I
have employees if my employees speak out
in you know in in terrible awful evil
ways there are punishments and there are
consequences okay the idea that Jesse
Jackson is going to go around saying
that that employees are the same as
slaves is just insipid and again it's
insulting to slaves I mean you're really
gonna equate like Steph Curry with with
a slave
I don't think Steph Curry would do that
but if this is if this is the line that
we're gonna use from now on then then
race relations are basically done okay
other things that I hate this cartoon
appeared in the Berkeley student
newspaper a couple of days ago Alan
Dershowitz was speaking on Berkeley
student campus this one is directly from
their Sturmer i mean this is completely
from you know the the Nazi newspapers
it's a very ugly picture of Alan
Dershowitz with the hook nose and the
fat fat lips and it says the liberal
case for Israel and then behind and
there's sort of a board that he's
putting his face through speaking to
students and then behind the board
there's a foot stomping what appears to
be a Palestinian person with a
Palestinian flag and in his hand and IDF
soldiers shooting a child okay this is
just pure anti-semitic rebel the idea
that number one IDF soldiers are just
going around shooting Palestinian
children for no reason at all for fun of
it and that Alan Dershowitz is being
paid off by these people because he's a
Jewish front basically for for evil Jews
you could legitimately remove the the
caption the liberal case for Israel just
right Judaism and then you could remove
the caption IDF and just put a Jewish
star and this would look like it's
directly from a Nazi newspaper no
retractions from the uc-berkeley
newspaper pretty insane stuff okay
quickly we're gonna deconstruct the
culture and then I have a surprise for
frequent listeners of the ben shapiro
show so i'm deconstructing the culture
every tuesday we take a little bit of
culture and we deconstruct it so here is
the culture we are going to deconstruct
today mmm who also appears to be
basically mike pence he's sort of turned
into mike pence when he takes off that
hat he's got the white hair and they're
they're there their hair they look at it
identical Eminem in an attempt to seek
relevance has decided to alienate half
of his audience
I suggesting that President Trump is
evil and he did a freestyle rap to this
effect at the at the Black Entertainment
Television Awards here's what he said
okay so this is this is the genius of
Eminem we have heard that this man is a
kin to Beethoven this is only Beethoven
after he had suffered from lead
poisoning presumably even then Beethoven
was still writing good stuff death and
poisoned by lead I'm pretty sure that's
not equivalent so he's a genius because
he can come up with a bunch of near
rhymes for the word pot congratulations
this is this is just genius stuff I also
like that cultural appropriation is fine
so long as you're a leftist - hates
Trump right so he's
culturally-appropriate a lot of obvious
you know black rap culture here clearly
I mean this has been Eminem stick for a
very long time and then he can use
phrases like this now I got a hatchet
like a damn Apache wood a tomahawk
totally fine right no no cultural
appropriation there no and nothing
insulting there right that's that's not
insulting in any way but that's just
because he is he's just a genius leftist
who hates president Trump apparently he
attended an NBA game in Detroit and he
was he was cheered Kid Rock however was
booed Kid Rock by the way says he's no
longer gonna run for Senate so just like
General Sherman if nominated he will not
he will not run if if elected he will
not serve Kid Rock has now stated the
same except he screamed really loud and
said by de huaah de bunda gun at the
same time okay other things final
deconstructing the culture point Mark
Wahlberg has now come out and repented
for doing the movie Boogie Nights now
I've never actually seen this film I've
heard that it's a very good movie
mathis you've seen the movie No so I've
heard that it's good but it is obviously
glorification of the pornography
industry is the idea of it anyway and he
said he asked God to forgive him for
some of his past movie roles especially
Boogie Nights
he was speaking with Cardinal blase
cupich in or blaze ku pitch in Chicago
this past weekend and he said I hope God
is a movie fan and also forgiving
because I've made some poor choices in
my past and he said the Boogie Nights is
up there at the top of the list good for
him
I think good for him I believe in the
capacity for a dump ssin and forgiveness
that's one of the things religion is all
about and it's good to see some people
in Hollywood who have the capacity to
look back at things that they've done
and say perhaps that was a bad idea okay
now I have a surprise for all of you the
surprise is that for years literally
years here on the bench Shapiro Cheryl
you have heard me talk about Burge
school
and you have wondered who are these bird
school people what do they do why are
they special well joining us here on the
bench Shapiro show we decided to have on
Philippe's a precious metals specialist
from Birch gold Philip welcome to the
Ben Shapiro show thanks for having me
back okay so first of all cool accent
second of all let's start by by asking
you what it what do you think the market
is going right now look I mean it looks
tough you look at the big picture and we
have I think a number of different
problems debt currently is a big issue
here in the United States we're holding
more debt than we ever have before
and of course the stock market looks
problematic to say the least I mean it's
been going up and up and up and up but
it's the nature of that growth I think
that it's been so concerning look for
example at stock prices versus company
earnings historically out of proportion
in today's climate we've seen it in two
other occasions historically 29 before
the crash that ultimately sparked the
Great Depression and more recently in
the year 2000 so the numbers are not
looking good okay so given that fact
I've said many times on the show that
one way to protect yourself is diversify
by investing in precious metals but what
makes Birch gold different than other
groups of people who are trying to sell
precious metals okay I think there's a
number of things first of all you look
at our track record we have a plus
ratings with the Better Business Bureau
longevity and a solid history more than
that I would say the approach I mean
look we know that there are tough times
and I think in in tough times the fear
mongers come out that's one thing that
we're you know very we stress a lot look
there is a rational argument for
precious metals in today's climate and I
think fear just clouds the
decision-making process so we guide our
clients through very carefully we make
sure that things are done effectively
and that honesty is something that I
definitely appreciate can you explain
sort of how a client goes through the
process if they want to get involved
with Birch gold do they call you up do
they go to your website and then how
does that process actually work of
course I mean they can go to our website
birchgold.com slash Ben they can get a
free info kit they're typically our
clients will contact us and we will
guide them through the
process so we have an understanding of
what they're trying to achieve we can
make recommendations and really handle
the process from start to finish whether
it's a cash purchase or protecting IRA
funds we handle everything and that's
one of the things that I really
appreciate about you guys that you are
honest about looking at people's
financial situations and and helping
them come to the correct conclusions so
again it's birchgold.com / ben if you
want to go check it out and and they are
the people that I trust with precious
metals investment as I say before you
know everyone I think should have at
least some of their money in precious
metals and right now one of the things
that you've been pitching for a while is
the idea that you can shift your 401 K
or IRA into precious metals IRA how
would that work yeah absolutely so first
of all you know one can move all or a
portion of any 401 K or IRA that you
have in terms of the mechanics it's very
simple you know I always say to clients
you need to determine you know what
you're looking to do how much you're
looking to work with but at that point
we can handle the process I mean we have
an in-house IRA Department they will
fill out paperwork and essentially
manage the heavy lifting between
custodian so we do the work the client
makes the decision of course well folks
if you're interested in investing with
Birch gold then you can talk to somebody
like Philip I going over to
birchgold.com /ban who knows if you get
that accent on the other end of the
phone then it is Philips but in any case
Philip thanks for joining the show
really appreciate it thanks okay so
tomorrow we'll be back with much much
more we'll give you the update on the
tax plan and I would like to talk a
little bit more about some of the good
stuff that's happening that people
aren't talking about we'll get to all of
that tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]